[Music]
hey everyone my name is gal shafir uh
and I lead our Global Security architect
team here at Google Cloud Security in in
our demo today I'm going to show you how
our groundbreaking Chronicle security
operations platform uh enable security
teams to detect investigate and respond
to cyber threats with the speed scale
and intelligence of Google the platform
overall is built out of Three core pie
pieces Sim sore in applied thread
intelligence all of which are natively
built into a single unified solution
that is easy to set up and use uh and it
really supports security analysts and
Engineers through their entire journey
of collecting the logs normalizing and
enriching them with more data uh
detecting threats and searching through
them to the operationalized uh side of
operationalizing them making them
actionable through case management
collaboration Auto aut at playbooks and
triage to really the decision- making
process uh and and ending up in a
resolution uh and to make things even
better we supercharge our Chronicle
secops platform with du AI which is
Google Cloud uh Cloud uh AI collaborator
that provides generative AI powered
assistance to make things even easier
for people to adopt and see uh quick
value out of it so on the you know Flow
Part of of the platform um this is kind
of what it looks like right on the Sim
side I'll say that Google certainly
knows a thing or two about scale and
searching through large amounts of data
is you know literally what Google uh is
known for doing en lightning speed uh
Google has applied the same scale in
speed to Chronicle so it can ingest huge
amounts uh of data uh and analyze it uh
from you know multicloud environments
stas environments and on- premise
environments um to detect an invest
instigate threats on the sore piece uh
Google Cloud's you know uh recent
acquisition of simplify uh you know for
security automation orchestration
respond um and it's designed to enable
security teams to collaborate manage
their sock and to automate workflows and
respond to threats within minutes
instead of hours or
days on the applied threat intelligence
side which really goes across this
entire platform throughout the entire
Journey I think that many security
vendors can say that you know can talk
the talk but very few of them can really
walk the walk and I'm sure a lot of
vendors out there can claim that they
have great in thre Intel but very few if
any can claim that they're actively
protecting billions of users and
mailboxes and devices and browsers on a
daily basis uh and as a result Google
has built its own thesis around what
good threat Intel should look like now
combined that internal knowledge that
Google has with virus toal which is the
world's largest crowdsource thread Intel
Observatory with mandian thread Intel
which is one of the world's leading QA
detection intelligence sources that
exist today in the world and you get
what we' like to call the largest threat
telescope in the world uh which is now
available to customers and Infused into
our SEC Ops offering as part of this
platform so um let me put my junior
security hat on uh and start by diving
into this case CU which is really the
place where analysts spend most of their
time all of those cases that you can see
here on the left were created by alerts
that were ingested by detection rules uh
including our outof the-box curated
detections and out of the box UA
detections uh or really by any other
supported data source like monitored
fishing mailboxes or other thirdparty
SIM vendors that can be plugged in ETC
of course that the Automation and respon
B has been processing this queue already
closing out a lot of noise and false
positives um so the queue that you see
here includes only the alerts that still
need my input on um some of these alerts
have mature playbooks and merely require
analyst validation uh to finalize
remediation and some alerts and cases
here uh have completed triage and
enrichment and are ready for us to dive
deeper into communication and
Remediation so let's just open this this
uh cryptocurrency uh mining
case the first thing that we'll see is
that Chronicle uses patented technology
to group rated alerts into threat
Centric
cases this way an analyst handles a
threat oriented case as opposed to
individual uh alerts and events uh that
would probably go to different analyst
that are actually probably a part of the
same Potential Threat so I'm about to to
start investigating this cryptocurrency
mining case uh which grouped two
seemingly unrelated alerts um the First
Alert tab is noticed as the malware
detection from our outof the boox EDR
detection rules uh and the second alert
tab uh notifies me of a crypto mining
activity that has been detected by
Google's security Command
Center this is probably indicating
malicious activity and I'm being asked
to take action and contain the end point
but before I take that action I want to
further understand what's going on
normally uh in order to understand this
case uh and what's going on here I would
need to take some time to figure out
what the threat is um and how it affects
my organization I would also need to
probably go through all of the alerts
grouped in this case one by one and
check all the events and entities and
enrichment from The Playbook that are
involved here and I would also probably
need to go through the case wall and see
you know the Playbook results and
outcomes and decide uh if any further
steps should be taken however now that I
click on the case uh tab I see that duet
AI has automatically collected all of
the full context and then summarized the
case for me front and center in fact
based on the guidance here I see where
things are at why should I consider
looking at this case with a higher
priority plus recommendations on what
the next steps uh to respond to the
threats um further by clicking on the
explore button here on the top right I
can see the entities graph correlating
the common entities involved with this
detection for the alerts and in this
case I can see it's you know involved
with an asset labeled as Lin
minor1 so going back to the top of the
alert here um I see that there's a
Playbook um that was designed for the
scenario actually and was automatically
triggered for this alert and it actually
has a pending action right we'll explore
playbooks in more detailed but for now
um I can see right away uh that by you
know clicking on The View Playbook tab I
can actually pivot to my playbook um and
when I do that I see that the Playbook
has sent some emails and rent some
thread intelligence performed enrichment
made some
decision um and also gathered contextual
data on the Endo from crowd strike in
this case this is really helpful for me
uh so far but really before taking the
further action here of containing the
Endo or escalating the case I just want
to have a further understanding of the
type of malir that has been detected by
chronical um curated detection rules um
with leveraging the the thread Intel
that we have here from viral and ment
and then I want to scope out the impact
of this malare to my
environment so um I'm going to start
that uh process by clicking on the
overview tab from The Playbook and
pivoting
here once I'm in the malware detection
overview here I scroll down uh to review
the malware verdict right with 46 out of
70 um engines as positive provided by
virus toal alongside the malicious
confidence rating which is 100 as you
can see here provided by the Mandan
thread intelligence by the way both of
those thread Intel sources are included
as part of our Enterprise Plus SEC Ops
uh package for
customers so at this point I understand
that I need to quickly scope the impact
of this malware to my environment and
start moving forward with a
response to learn more about this threat
that I'm facing I can see what the virus
toal Community is saying about this
threat uh in the attribution tab right
so I see all the comments here from the
community and now um that I verify that
the crowdsource intelligence suggests me
that I'm dealing with something probably
malicious here I can decide to Pivot
into mainan curated detection and see
what the mandiant Intel analysts have
curated around this threat uh to learn
more about the risk for my industry for
my organization thread
tactics and targets here um so I can
click on the ment link right here um to
see what the analysis is in the man and
Advantage platform it really gives me
much more visibility into this threat so
I can quickly quickly see uh what are
the threat actor attributes in malare
associations I can figure out quickly
who is targeting uh why and what are
other ioc's that are known to be related
to this threat so I can later add them
potenti essentially to my chronical
investigation and extend it by hunting
for them in my
environment I see that this hash is
linked to a threat actor called
ap43 and clearly if I click on that I
see that there's a lot of attributes and
articles and associations and ioc's
related to it um that really refer to it
in the mandian advantage
platform um but in order to see all of
them I can actually you know decide to
run a search on that term ap43 to get to
all of
them normally um I'd had to you know
maybe write a report about this threat
that's targeting my industry but
normally I'd have to parse through
11,000 plus results to you know spend
time figuring out which thread
intelligence uh reports and thread Intel
objects are related to my mission and
decide which core takeaways are relevant
but now with do AI I see the content on
this thread actor in recently summarized
from ment massive corpse of Intel data
plus this model is grounded which helps
reduce uh LM hallucinations and means
that I have accurate summaries to use in
my reporting uh that I might want to
create for my team including my ceso and
sock manager I can immediately see here
in the report and in the summary um that
this threat Intel uh this threat uh is
deploying crypto miners uh and is
targeting Financial
organization um Android op developers
and journalists and now that I
understand all of this context I can
pivot back to my case with all the new
understandings that I
have so when scoping out a malware like
uh case like this you'd need to access
uh some historical EDR data to confirm
if there are other assets that have been
observed and associated with the malware
uh hashes for example um and you need to
be able to search the historical EDR
data very quickly
regardless of of the data volumes and
and the formats of the data the beauty
about chronical Security operation is
that it's enabling you to do that across
huge amounts of data sets with a single
click so let me show you by clicking the
explore button here right next to this
um red file hash to see if there's more
context around this
hash once I click explore I immediately
see that there's three distinct assets
that have been observed with this crypto
minire uh hash right related to them in
past events so my scope just went from
one asset to three dating back to August
22nd to uh to 2023 with potentially Lin
minor 03 being patient
zero most likely this maler at the time
was unknown and maybe have gone
undetected but this is a great example
of why organizations should return
retain their EDR data for long long
period of time with Chronicle our
default retention period for all data is
one year and that's all hot and
actionable Chronicle also automatically
stitches together multiple data sets
into investigative views such as hash
views or asset views to increase the
anus productivity and enable them to
quickly take actions on saw cases so one
example is by clicking the first observe
button here with a time stamp Associated
to to lean minor
03 um and piecing together the event
timeline of really what happened on this
case just before and after the malware
has been seen so uh we can really see
the full
story so we quickly see within the event
timeline that the user has logged into
their PC and maybe opened an Excel file
sheet could be uh you know a macro
that's been running and immediately
after really opening the the Excel the
malicious uh activity has
started another way to run
investigations through all of the
chronical data is through the Sim search
or what we like to call the udm search
which stands for unified data
model um so I understand uh and and
really to decide to run the search
through pedabytes of data I can run a
search for maybe crypto mining attack
Google Cloud last week to see if there's
any other alerts in my Google Cloud
environment that could potentially be
related to my
investigation usually in order to
conduct the search I have to know what
EDM uh udm Fields uh to use I need to
know and type very specific Syntax for
my query and frankly I need to be
patient since queries can be large and
challenging to create uh and to deliver
exactly what I want to see but now with
du AI it automatically translate my
search query to Chronicles unique data
model so I can run that search here or
even add it in line and update the
search in real
time so my query has resulted when I
rent it uh in finding related events and
I can click on the event to get more
information about it including the raw
data if I need it the severity and risk
score from Chronicle and I can see that
there's also an active investigation and
case running for it uh which is really
by the way the case that we started from
in this case so I can just click this
button uh to easily pivot back to the
existing crypto mining case for summary
we just walked through a unified sock
workflow from initial case triage to
understanding the malware intelligence
and then scoping out the potential
impact to my environment in a matter of
a few
minutes I now feel confident about
taking action um and really make you
know to make things easier for me um The
Playbook summarizes all the remediation
actions um that I may want to take in
one central place I can see that I can
contain the endpoint and escalate uh the
case to my sock manager uh for further
response Etc what's great about
Chronicle uh is that there's many
hundreds and hundreds of built-in
Integrations so I don't even have to
open another console or be an expert on
my EDR platform just clicking on the
done button will execute the remediation
sequence uh and contain the endpoint for
me simple as that thank you all for
watching see you next
[Music]
time